hundreds of migrants and asylum seekers
sheltered from the cold and rain as
French police evacuated a camp in
northern Paris before dawn among them
families with young children for months
nearly 2,000 people had been living in
desperate conditions in flimsy tents
wedged between roads with no sanitation
most were from Sudan Somalia or
Afghanistan it's a really bad condition
for all immigration here is not good
environment it's very cold the weather
is too cold and also every time it's
rain
I mean the ground is sweet it's not for
good for life in recent years police
have evacuated a number of similar camps
in the city the mayor of Paris said the
situation was inhumane and she urged the
French government to do more to help
Jacque Vaughn was a dis and silikal you
had proof each time we're told it won't
happen again if we don't want this to
happen again we need a proper system
that recognizes people's rights and
gives them a dignified reception our
country should be capable of this as
daylight broke people carried their
possessions and boarded buses French
authorities said they'd be taken to
shelters in the Paris region to assess
whether they had the right to apply for
asylum as workers began cleaning up
police said officers would remain on
site to prevent future camps in the area
the road here remains closed but most
the tents have been cleared away the
cleanup operation is continuing but what
is happening is that there are some
migrants who are coming back they
perhaps live somewhere else last night
and they're finding that all their
possessions have gone and they don't
know what to do this Somali man didn't
want to be identified but he told me
that he'd lost all his belongings he
said it was the third time had been
evacuated from a camp in Paris an
experience that campaigners say is all
too common we don't know yet what
solutions are proposed
besides temporary housing in a Sports
Hall we have to think about the
long-term and not only about today
that's what's important yes some people
are leaving today but what will happen
in two weeks in a year can those
stay in this housing and not go back to
living on the streets the camp clearance
comes one day after the French
government announced new measures to
tighten its immigration policy assigned
for some that the government serious
about cracking down but activists say
the evacuation is little more than
political PR because unless there's a
better system to humanely manage
migrants who arrived in France
vulnerable people will continue to end
up in the street
Natasha Butler al Jazeera Paris